hey you guys welcome back to my flickers
of fear show on which we talk about
good horror movies
so today i mean okay so i feel like on a
few of my previous reviews particularly
i'm thinking about the one that i did
have unfriended
i kind of said and i've said this on
some of our other shows as well that i'm
not the biggest fan of found footage
horror movies it's not that i you know
just
dismiss them out of hand like it's like
oh it's found footage [ __ ] that um it's
not like that but it's not usually a
genre that i seek out unless i've heard
a lot about a particular movie being
really good
but even having said that um if you ask
me to come up with uh you know
a list of you know really really good
found footage movies i can think of like
a whole bunch like right out the gate so
it's not so much that i'm biased against
that subgenre in particular because like
i said a lot of movies that i really
like like lake mungo or the bay or
something like that um you know hell
house llc rec r found footage found
footage can be done well just like any
other subgenre now the movie we're
talking about today is one that i
definitely think is found footage done
right and this is the taking of deborah
logan this came out in 2014
and this was actually the first movie
by a dude named adam robital
and he actually went on to do
he did insidious the last key like a
couple years later and then he did
escape room which actually we saw in the
theater and actually didn't really get
that good of reviews but i actually
quite enjoyed it um and he also made the
sequel to that which i didn't even know
there was one but okay and then later
it's well i have to see that now too but
um he also did i think he co-wrote one
of the paranormal activity movies it was
ghost dimension
and um last i heard i think he's working
with darren aronofsky of all people for
like a netflix series so we'll see if
that ever comes to pass that's pretty
recently that that news came out so
we'll see how it goes
but there's something really i mean this
movie it's kind of like a lot of people
compare it to the last exorcism which
was also excellent it was also kind of
like a found footage movie because this
one spoiler alert is kind of a
possession story it does have like a
supernatural element to it
but it's kind of more i want to say like
at least at the beginning it's more
grounded in reality and it's not really
grounded so much
in you know a demon possession or you
know in a christian framework i guess
like a lot of possession movies are this
is one of those movies that has a really
really high like critical score but then
the audience scores are kind of mixed
and so
most of the reviews like on horror sites
i saw were really good um particularly
it's like you know this is one of the
best found footage movies you know
recent of recent years which i would
totally agree with because there's
something really really great and really
creepy about this one
but
some people didn't like
um the way that it went from like this
kind of grounded ambiguous sort of thing
into like full-on supernatural
and i can see that but i didn't really
mind it and like i said even though it
is essentially
possession i guess is what you're
talking about so it's just kind of like
another possession found footage movie i
think that it had it does something
different enough that i definitely think
it elevates it like over some of the
other ones in the genre because i know
there's a million i know there's a
million found footage possession movies
and i'm just saying saying like the last
last exorcism which i'll probably get
around to reviewing one of these days
too which is also really good um and
which a lot of people compare this to
but like i said it's not really it's not
done in like an exorcisty like you know
this is a christian demon sort of thing
it is kind of like demonic possession
but not exactly it has its own kind of
mythology and i think that's like kind
of cool so it does something sort of
different another thing elevating this i
think
is
the
particularly the two acting performances
which kind of like at the center of this
now deborah logan herself is played by
jill larson and if you're old like me
you will remember that back in the day
uh she had a very very long term i can't
remember how long she was on there but
she was on that soap opera that was on i
think it was on abc like back in day all
my children she played opal on there um
which i remember because my grandma used
to love that show so it was like always
on when i was growing up so yeah so she
was um so she's in this movie like
playing like an elderly lady who's
suffering from alzheimer's
and she is great i mean the her
performance in this is just so
it's so fearless like she totally went
for it and i really think i mean her
being at the center of this really
really kind of is one of the best things
about the movie she's great i mean her
performance in this is great i also love
uh the actress playing her daughter and
ramsay
um because the relationship between them
there's just so much
going on like in the relationship
between the two of them that a lot of
it's kind of like unspoken but a lot but
a lot of it like still comes through
like through their glances and stuff and
ramsay i think she's best known for uh
mad about you but she's been in like a
ton of other [ __ ] she was but like on a
ton of television a ton of movies um i
remember her from the l word um she was
on dexter like she was on some episodes
of that so she's been a [ __ ] ton of
stuff as well and she is also great so i
think like the the mother-daughter
dynamic in this movie is one of the
things that really like elevates it um
kind of
above some other movies in this sub
genre
so what we have uh going on in this
movie
is that
it's basically i guess it's so it's
found footage but it's kind of like a
mockumentary kind of thing too because
you have um a young woman named mia
and she is like a phd student so one of
so she's studying i'm assuming she's
like a medical student or something like
that
so she's doing her phd thesis she's
making a documentary about alzheimer's
disease and in particular not only just
um you know how alzheimer's disease like
ravages the person who has it but also
how it affects the primary caregiver
like the person that has to take care of
them and so she wants to document a
relationship between a caregiver and a
person with alzheimer's and kind of like
um you know get that dynamic
so she's making a documentary so she
comes to this house in virginia with her
film crew uh two guys named gavin and
luis
and um initially you're okay so you're
ki it's set up
that sarah who's this who's the daughter
she has come
to this kind of remote house in virginia
where she grew up like a long time ago
to care for her mother like i said the
relationship between the mother and
daughter is not exactly strained but
there's a lot of kind of i don't know if
i'd go as far as to call it like
resentment but you can tell that debra
even like the way she dresses the way
she carries herself she comes across as
very proper like she's a very um
not prim exactly but she's she's very
polite there's a you know there's a way
of doing things which in a way like
makes her
being ravaged by alzheimer's and then
something else later on even more tragic
there's a lot of sadness in this movie
too because you can tell that this poor
woman you know she always wants to look
like all put together she has like her
little you know
all her little crisp neat clothes and
her little pearls and everything and she
just very wants to be very proper but
then this disease like she doesn't have
any control over her own body anymore
and she's like losing control of it and
she's like you know run around naked and
all this other kind of thing she doesn't
have any control and like i said and
that's really uh sad and when she's
lucid
she's aware that she's doing these
things she's aware that she's losing her
memory that her mind is slipping away
from her so it's like really really sad
but um you know that said it's like her
and her daughter i guess she's never
come to terms with the fact because
she's so proper and upright and
everything and everything needs to be
done a certain way
um you know there are rules she has
never really come to terms with the fact
that her daughter is gay
and she acknowledges it but she's always
like takes little digs you know what i
mean like about her like masculine
clothes and things of that nature so
it's not it's not overt but you can tell
that there's kind of some simmering a
little bit of [ __ ] simmering there um
that said though sarah is actually she's
a great character because as soon as she
she basically i guess she set up this
whole thing with this documentary crew
because the documentary crew are paying
them like uh you know to be in the
documentary they she got a bunch of
grant money and she's going to use it to
help um keep the house because i guess
the house is in danger being foreclosed
upon because deborah won't sell it and
also obviously to pay some of their i'm
sure horrendous medical bills so it's
kind of established early on that they
really really need to be in this
documentary and sarah is the one that
has set it up
now when the film crew first get there
mia who is kind of portrayed she's not
portrayed super negatively but she is
kind of a little bit mercenary in the
sense that
you don't know if she really i mean she
has like a character arc into the movie
later on but you don't really get the
sense she's like well she's just worried
about her documentary she just wants um
you know a subject to document that's
gonna let her come like into their house
like over it ends up being like two
months um you know where they're in and
out and they're just kind of like this
is gonna let her film all this stuff and
she doesn't really
at first seem to care about them as
people she's just kind of like this is
my movie and i'm making this movie about
it and she even does something really
shitty like early on where to get
deborah because deborah like when the
crew first shows up debra is starting to
have second thoughts and she's like i
really feel like you know this is going
to exploit me and i don't wanna do it
and all this other stuff so
uh mia tries to get her back by saying
oh my grandfather had alzheimer's so
this movie is very important to me but
then you find out later on that mia lied
about that her grandparents are actually
still alive and do not have alzheimer's
so you know like i said a little bit
mercenary
but as it goes on like sarah is able to
convince deborah it's like look we need
the money you're gonna lose the house um
you know if we don't participate in this
this is our last shot so you know like a
week later they invite the film crew
back and you know the film presumably
like living there because they're in
this room with um you know with
mattresses and stuff and like i said
again deborah very proper she's like you
know boys and girls don't sleep together
in this house even though these are like
grown-ass people she's like so she makes
like the two men like sleep in one room
and then you know mia has to stay in
another room they can't stay together so
it's just so it's that kind of whole
situation so as they're documenting
there's little bits of you know mia kind
of there's not a lot of this but there's
because the nice thing about this movie
uh particularly in the found subgenre is
that it's not really focused that much
on the film crew which i think was a
really good decision and not something
you see a lot because i kind of feel
like in found footage that's kind of the
whole point that you know the people
that are filming it are kind of like the
main characters this one not so much um
they're in it but they're kind of like
on the periphery the you know the main
bulk of the action is concerned with
deborah and sarah their relationship and
all the crazy [ __ ] that's happening and
then the film crew just kind of like
along for the ride because they just
happened to be there filming it so i
really kind of like that was again like
a little bit of a different take than
what you'd normally see in found footage
and that's why i think this works so
well because you know it's not focused
on them it's more focused on the main
characters and the two characters you
know sarah and debra like together are
great
so mia kind of like talks to him and
she's talking about what alzheimer's is
and how you know and how it affects the
brain like you know kind of talks about
the science behind it and then talks
about how harmful it is for the person
having to uh care for the person with
alzheimer's and how you know tragic and
sad it is and everything and so they
kind of go a little bit into that and
then so they're interviewing deborah and
at first she seems like pretty lucid
most of the time but then she kind of
like starts forgetting
little things like you know what's i
painted this bird and what's this bird
called and things like that and then
they're interviewing
sarah so debra is like at first trying
to like i said she's still mostly lucid
while they're interviewing her and she's
kind of trying to downplay it you know
it's like oh you know i have senior
moments sometimes like i'll toast the
bread twice because i forgot that i
already toasted it and then sarah kind
of comes in and goes yeah but that one
time you left the stove on and like
burned half the kitchen down so you know
it's it's a little bit worse than you're
like letting on so she's just kind of
like okay whatever so as the as the
story goes on like i said her kind of
senior moments if you want to call him
that are getting a little bit more
severe and at first it seems
kind of legit like still stuff that
people with alzheimer's would do like
the the big thing that happens like the
first thing that happens because mostly
it's just like little stuff like she's
kind of wandering around like she forgot
where she was and stuff like that but
then
one evening most of the crew and
everybody like they hear people they
hear screaming like down in the kitchen
and they go down there and find that
debra is basically uh threatening gavin
with a knife because she accused him of
stealing her spade which is another
thing she's really into gardening you'll
find out why later on but uh so a lot of
times they'll go out in the middle of
the night and they'll find her like
digging in the garden with her spades or
her spade is like very important to her
and she thinks for whatever reason that
gavin stole it so she's basically
threatened threatening to like straight
up stab his ass and uh you know so it's
a little alarming so as it goes on like
i said there's
it's kind of a thing where you know it
seems to like progress really quickly
but at first it still seems like
you know something that people with
alzheimer's would do like i said just
like wandering around like escaping from
the you know house in the middle of the
night she's like nailing the windows
shut she's like she seems to think
there's an intruder outside even though
like in the motion lights come on even
though there's doesn't look like there's
anybody out there so
at first so it's but it starts getting
worse and worse at which point uh sarah
goes to talk to her regular doctor dr
nazir dr nazir says um you know i know
that i told you that it was going to
take like two or three years to really
progress to a point to this point but
you know this now it's like seems like
it's really more aggressive and it's
like spread way quicker than we thought
that it would um so we really need to
put her on more medication and uh you
know stave this off for as long as
possible at this point though something
really creepy happens
they have they started setting up
because she started because deborah has
started like wandering around at night
like getting out of bed and like going
outside and like i said climbing out
windows and [ __ ] like that so they're
afraid she's gonna hurt herself so they
basically um put up kind of not hidden
cameras but they put up you know cameras
like all over the house to kind of keep
an eye on her so there's one in her
bedroom there's one of the hallways and
all this other kind of stuff so they set
all that up and then one night
apparently she goes down to the kitchen
and she's like standing in front of the
stove and when gavin is watching the
footage later on there's a really weird
moment and this actually kind of creeped
me out like the first time i saw it like
little things like this it's not i'm not
like super into like jump scares or
anything like that but it's just like
little [ __ ] like this is what creeps me
out so there's footage of her and she's
standing in front of the stove and then
all of a sudden pop she's like standing
on the stove and gavin's looking at this
going you guys there is no skip in the
time code there wasn't a thing where
like the camera went off for a second
and then she climbed up on the stove
it's like basically she was on the floor
she was on the top of the stove and we
can't really explain that and gavin at
this point who they've kind of
established is um kind of a believer
he's like he was raised catholic and he
still like seems a little bit religious
so at this point he's just like y'all um
i think something is going on here
besides alzheimer's because this is like
some creepy ass [ __ ] and uh but everyone
else is just kind of like no it just
must be some kind of technical glitch or
whatever now one night in particular uh
too like after that happens
there's this kind of i guess like when
um when deborah was younger
her husband died like only only like two
or three years into their marriage like
back in the 70s and so she was kind of
forced to raise sarah all on her own
and what she did was she started her own
business doing like uh she was a
switchboard operator so she started her
own uh switchboard business and was very
successful and she um you know before
she kind of started going alzheimer like
on the you know when they interviewed
her she's like basically i was the nexus
of this whole town like she knew all the
secrets and she knew everything that was
going on because you know that's and she
had to like keep her mouth shut you know
to keep her business going but she was
like actually really good at it and so
she still has her old 1970s vintage
switchboard equipment up in the attic
and um sarah says to the crew that it
hasn't worked like in a really long time
but one night
uh they're all awakened by
the switchboard making a really really
horrible like a really loud like phone
ringing sound and sarah's sitting there
going uh you know how could that be like
that [ __ ] hasn't worked in years so they
go up to the attic and they find debra
like naked and she's sitting in front of
the switchboard like just punching it
into this one uh hole
and so they're sitting there
you know who did that who did that
belong to because they go to talk to the
doctor and the doctor is like well this
is obviously a memory that's bothering
her and maybe if you can figure out like
what's at the bottom of it you know
maybe you can kind of purge her of it
and she'll stop like acting so crazy so
they're like so this hole is like it's
337 or whatever so they try to go
through like all her because they say
you know like mom's a hoarder she has
everything and this house is like really
really big and it has like all this
attic space
so sarah's basically like well she kept
all of her records like from back in the
day when she was a switchboard operator
so we just have to find out who that uh
who that particular phone line belonged
to and maybe we can kind of tease out
what's going on
so they find out that line 337 belonged
to a dude named andrei desjardin who
back in the 70s was like a local
pediatrician
he had moved from quebec now they also
find out
that
uh at the time he was actually they
hadn't convicted him or anything like
that but they actually suspected that he
was involved in a series of murders of
little girls who had basically been
found they had like these weird like
snake things like um snake uh shapes or
whatever like into their like carved
into their foreheads and they'd actually
been injected with snake venom and uh
and had been murdered there were four of
them and then uh desjardins went missing
and nobody knew what happened to him for
like 30 years and so they there's like
an old documentary it's funny because
there's like a documentary within this
was like a different documentary like
from the 70s so they show like parts of
that and i think it's called river rouge
or rouge river or something like that
where you know it's kind of about the
murders of these little girls
and then they find out too and like i
said this is kind of where it goes in a
more supernatural direction
that what desjardin was trying to do
like after they found his house or you
know the place that he was killing the
girls or whatever they found out that he
was trying to
do this
ritual um i think it was like the
monacan uh indian tribe and they uh he
was trying to do this ritual because he
was dying of lou gehrig's disease and he
wanted to essentially like pop his soul
out like and put it in another host so
he could be immortal
and apparently to do this
ritual you needed to kill five girls who
were just starting their periods it was
like a blood sacrifice and um so it was
a whole like snake eating its tail like
an oroboros type of thing
there's a lot so there's a lot of like
snake symbology
and uh so that starts to tie in with
other [ __ ] that's been happening with
deborah not only the fact that she
starts kind of growling like possessing
talking but like in french and also her
skin she starts to get like these weird
like skin infections and the doctors
don't really know what this is because
they're like look this is not associated
with alzheimer's we have no idea what
the [ __ ] this is um like her skin is
starting to look like really scaly and
like she starts like pulling pieces of
it off like it's just kind of slopping
off you know what i mean so there's so
that's kind of like tying in with the
whole snake motif which comes off later
on
so as it turned out so kind of as they
go on they find out that
what actually happened to desjardin
was that uh he had killed those four
girls and then the fifth victim because
they're supposed to be five like for the
ritual to work uh the fifth victim was
actually supposed to be sarah when she
was a little girl it's like back in 1976
or whatever so deborah and her best
friend and neighbor harris like found
out about this and deborah straight up
killed the dude's ass and then they
buried him alive like they buried him
out in the garden and then they just
like kept mum about it like all these
years but it turned out that because
deborah had developed alzheimer's and
therefore her resistance was weakened
that essentially desjardine was like
taking over her body
um so he could complete the ritual and
you know keep on going so that's what i
thought was so great about this was that
even though
obviously um you know deborah does have
alzheimer's disease you're not really
sure at which point
it was just alzheimer's or when it was
like demonic [ __ ] and the sad thing
about this too like i said this is if
you think about the implications of the
story it's actually really sad too
because
as the story goes on and her behavior
gets like more and more like like a
possessed person she says things and
does things which kind of
re-contextualizes a lot of the stuff
that she was doing at the beginning that
they thought was just like random weird
[ __ ] and it's actually really sad
because you realize that she knew what
was happening like the whole time and
couldn't really convey it to them um you
know like she knew the dude was coming
she knew the dude was because she kept
doing these paintings with like this
dark figure getting closer um she knew
who it was she knew that he was taking
over her body and she was like powerless
to stop it and at one point she even
tells her friend harris like she's in
the hospital because she's like [ __ ]
herself all up
you know she tells him to kill her so
she knows what's going on and that's
what's like really really scary about it
she knows that this dude has taken over
her body and she can't stop him from
doing it and essentially he's taken over
her body because he wants to finish the
ritual so while deborah is in the
hospital she straight up tries to kidnap
this little girl who's like dying of
cancer named kara and basically he's
trying to like take her away and she
does that one time but they actually get
the little girl back but then later on
because uh deborah keeps like flipping
out and like getting [ __ ] all
physically [ __ ] up she has to keep
going back to the hospital and when
she's in the hospital a second time she
essentially like grabs the girl again
and like takes her away like takes her
out of the hospital and at this point
they've actually figured out
where it is that she's going because
they said well desjardins used to take
his victims to this kind of old uh
abandoned mine and that's where the
ritual is supposed to take place so
that's essentially you know they know
that that's where she's going so they
kind of like confront her at the end
there and i think one of the best things
about this like i had seen i don't
remember if i saw this very famous
little scene or sequence prior to me
seeing this movie i thought just i had
heard about it but i don't know if i
actually saw it or if i just saw it out
of context but it's so great because
like i said it's possession but
they're going with like a different
mythology it's essentially she's turning
into like this snake demon type thing
but it's also desjardin
so
they go so the daughter and mia i mean
gavin like the other guy on the crew he
is [ __ ] off he was like the only smart
one in the bunch i guess like at some
point after the supernatural [ __ ] starts
out he's like yeah about uh and he
leaves it doesn't come back
but mia stays because as i said even
though she seemed kind of mercenary at
the beginning she does actually develop
kind of like she starts caring about
because you know this happens over like
the course of two months so she actually
does start caring about sarah and about
debra and wants to help them so sarah
and mia essentially like have to chase
deborah into this
mine shaft or compound or whatever to
try to get this little girl back because
they know that you know she's basically
gonna kill her and there's this just
great sequence where they're down in
this mine
uh and you know there's just a little
light or whatever and sarah like goes
around the corner and shines the
flashlight in her mom and she just gasps
and then mia comes around the corner and
you basically see debra
and her jaw is unhinged like a snake and
she's got this little girl's whole
entire head in her mouth and she's
basically like eating her and it's just
such a great
i mean i think that scene and pretty
like
like out of context i think that kind of
went around like almost as a meme in
itself just because it was such a
shocking
image i mean it was just like something
you don't really see just turned around
here's this old woman like eating this
[ __ ] kid's head and i was just kind
of like holy [ __ ] so that was just like
such a great [ __ ] image
uh you know but then they managed to
like rest the girl away and you know
then her mouth is like really really big
like a snake mouth but then she goes
back to normal and so they figure out by
talking to this like anthropologist and
everything that
what basically what they had to do was
they had to burn
desjardins remains because i guess the
remains had been buried in the backyard
like all this time
but
he had basically possessed deborah
that's why she was digging in the garden
all the time he had basically possessed
her to go and hey i need my body back
like i need to you know dig it up and
hide it somewhere because it was this
whole thing where
you had to like keep it around so i mean
even though he's like decomposing like
bones and stuff but so she had actually
like under his influence had dug it up
and hu and hid it like in the attic so
that nobody else could get it because
the only way to get rid of the demon
from out of debra was basically to
burn the corpse so
because they talked to the
anthropologist sarah and mia find out
this is what they're supposed to do so
they actually do find the body and end
up burning it uh at which point it seems
that the demon has left debra um and
even though she's killed several people
she actually killed a cop um like the
one cop that came in after her and she
wounded several others like she
she is has the ability to like spit
snake venom and stuff like that too so
she spit then she bites people and stuff
and gives them you know she puts snake
venom in their bloodstream so she [ __ ]
up like one cop when she was escaping
from the hospital and then she killed
one cop
and there's like all snakes everywhere
and [ __ ] like that but um you know they
kind of show at the very end that she
didn't get into trouble for doing that
obviously because she wasn't mentally in
her right mind and they kind of show her
leaving the hospital and she just looks
all [ __ ] up and like she's not even in
there anymore so it's really kind of
it's really kind of a sad ending because
even though the demon is out of her i
mean obviously she's not ever going to
be right again it wasn't like oh the
demon's gone and everything's okay she
still has alzheimer's and she's still
all [ __ ] up and and she's never gonna
get that back
so they have that and then they have
this nasty little thing at the end where
kara the girl with cancer that uh that
she tried to eat
um they do like a little news segment
it's like oh her leukemia went into
remission and she's celebrating her 10th
birthday and it's like so it's like you
know feel good story news story or
whatever and then at the very end like
the news guys like asking this little
girl hey what are you gonna do in the
future and stuff and she's like oh i
have plans and they're a secret and then
she looks at the camera like oh creepy
you know what i mean so obviously
desjardin has transferred himself into
this little girl uh so we'll see what
happens from then on but yeah so
as i said i'm found footage not my very
favorite sub genre it's not usually
something i would seek out even though
i've seen like a [ __ ] ton of good ones
um like i said i usually prefer
mockumentaries and this is kind of like
a mockumentary but it's also because
there are like documentary bits in it
because they're making a documentary but
it's also kind of like found footage it
does have a couple of the things that
people don't like about found footage
it's like you know particularly in the
third act like why would you still keep
filming but like i said you could say
that about any found footage movie so
i'm not gonna get all upset about it and
to be honest like when they're in the
mines at the end like mia and sarah like
when they're trying to get the little
girl back from deborah you know they you
could argue that they're using the
camera just because it has a light on it
you know what i mean so she's using the
light so they can see where they're
going because they're trying to like you
know get the girl back and not have
deborah see them and [ __ ] like that so
you know it's so i'll let i'll allow it
but like i said um the great thing about
this is that even though it's found
footage even though it's essentially a
possession story i really do like one
that they went a different way with the
possession mythology making it making
her like possessed by
a dude who was once alive but was trying
to like make himself immortal through
you know a native american uh snake
ritual essentially a sacrificial ritual
so i kind of like that they went that
angle instead of you know just the
regular
pazuzu type you know biblical demon type
thing so that's kind of cool and like i
said i think what really really elevates
this one
is the two performances the mother and
daughter at the center of the story and
the fact that the movie focuses on them
rather than on the film crew like i said
the phone car in it but they're kind of
just very peripheral um you don't even
see them all that much because they're
always kind of behind the camera it's
always always the focus is almost always
on debra and sarah and i think that was
a great uh that was a great idea that
was like a great um you know that's what
makes this movie great is because
particularly because those two women uh
the acting performances are just
phenomenal you can tell that deborah
like i said the woman that plays her
jill larsen who like i said was most
famous for all my children the soap
opera she just goes for it uh she's
fantastic in this she's simultaneously
very sympathetic and also terrifying
but she's not terrifying because
but she's also like i said a really
tragic character because she knows that
something bad is happening but she's
kind of powerless to stop it and once
you realize
as the movie goes on once you realize
later on that she was actually aware of
all this [ __ ] happening but couldn't
like communicate it or uh you know to to
the others or like couldn't get anybody
to help her you can you realize you you
feel like a lot more sympathy toward her
but she's also like really scary at the
same time because there's like some
shots of her where she's just like
playing a piano and then she like turns
her head and she's like super super
creepy looking and it's just kind of
like just you know and she's just like
an older lady she's not you know like a
monster she doesn't look like a monster
anything like that like at least not
until the end but just like the way she
looks and stuff like that it's just
really really creepy and like some of
the way she delivers some of the lines
is really creepy so it's just really
great that they kind of
went in that direction and um you know
often too like anne ramsey who plays
sarah is just so great you can tell that
she's really trying to put a brave face
on things she's very jocular um you know
she's trying to like keep everyone's
spirits up and stuff like that but you
can tell that she has a lot of her own
pain that this is really like killing
her like the stress of seeing her mother
going through this of having to care for
her mother um they show like a few
things like she's you know really
drinking a lot like to cope with it so
there's a lot of stuff going on under
the surface like particularly with the
relationship between these two which i
think really kind of uh enriches this
movie uh a lot and honestly i mean
however it is you feel about it going
like in a blatantly supernatural
direction because i feel like the last
exorcism which like i said a lot of
people have compared this to doesn't
really or it leaves it a lot more
ambiguous this one is very very
obviously goes in a supernatural
direction it takes a while to go there
but it does actually
you know end up being that's what that's
what the explanation is and i know that
that kind of like divided some audiences
i did not uh it did did not bother me it
didn't seem out of like left field or
anything like that i actually quite
liked uh that it went in that direction
i think i would have been disappointed a
little bit if they just kind of left it
oh we don't know if it's alzheimer's
normally i like ambiguity but i didn't
mind uh that it went in a blatantly
supernatural direction this time just
because i thought the mythology of it
was so cool and i like that they tied in
like a serial killer and like ritual
blood magic and stuff like that i
thought that was like pretty cool but
yeah so even if you don't like found
footage movies and i know a lot of
people don't this is actually one of the
best ones uh so if you haven't seen it
you definitely should and let me know
what you thought about the end because
like i said i know a lot of people were
kind of divided over the supernatural
aspect it's like maybe we should have
kept it more
you know a couple reviews i said was
like well i would have liked it better
if they had kept it more ambiguous as to
like whether it actually was alzheimer's
or whether she actually was possessed or
or maybe if like the daughter was maybe
thinking she was possessed because she
couldn't deal with the fact that her
mother was slipping away from her which
might have been a good angle too but
like i said i don't really mind the
supernatural uh stuff and some of the
scenes like later on like like i said
even little things like her like popping
up onto the stove and you know that
great reveal with her like eating the
girl's head and stuff like that it was
just like really really good creepy ass
imagery and i just think that was really
well done i think there was like a
really good
kind of dread inducing sort of
atmosphere through the whole thing and i
think a lot of that was due to the
acting you know as i said the two women
like jill larson and anne ramsey really
like knocked it out of the park and i
love that the movie like focuses on them
instead of the film crew i just thought
that was like a really great idea so
well like i said even if you don't like
found footage uh check this one out it's
actually really really good really worth
watching uh it's just some great imagery
and really really creepy i really liked
it i think this is maybe
i watched it earlier for like i watched
it yesterday for this review i think
this might be the third time that i've
seen it and i kind of like it better
each time because i think i pick up uh
more little things which you know that's
usually happens with every other movie
but uh yeah so i think it's on to be for
free
it was on shutter but i don't think it
is anymore at least not in the united
states but like i said you can watch it
on 2b for free and i think also uh you
can watch it on amazon prime if you have
a subscription i think it's free on
there as well so uh go check it out and
let me know what you thought about it in
the comments and that will do it for the
latest flickers of fear i will see you
guys on the next one
bye